[Musique]
ils partageaient le même rêve devenir
leur propre patron ils ont réussi en
passant par le microcrédit haram
catherine laurent et nadine vous livre
le secret de leur succès ça ressemble à
une conférence mais c'est bien une
remise de prix qui se tenait dans cette
salle de quétigny un grand jour pour
haram et catherine tous deux créateurs
d'entreprise
félicitations et bonne continuation de
générations différentes mais une
ambition commune être leur propre patron
et par le raid
une ambition concrétisait en 2018 par
ces commerçants indépendants et salué
cette année par l'adie l'organisme qui
les a soutenus à leurs débuts je suis
fier achevée ouais je suis fier je suis
contente
vraiment c je suis fier pour je suis
fier aussi par rapport pour mes enfants
aussi
ce prix on va raccrocher sur le mur en
grand que les jeunes puissent voir qu'on
est notre travail
et puis qu'on entre l'a10 et puis tous
ces gens qui sont derrière cette
association
catherine est récompensé car elle à
redynamiser son territoire nous le
verrons demain aujourd'hui place à haram
qui a décroché le prix jeunes ils
avaient moins de 30 ans lorsqu'il a
rencontré son conseiller et obtenu son
micro crédit pour ouvrir sacs à dassault
[Musique]
un diplôme de plus sur le mur et une
prime de 1000 euros pour continuer sur
sa lancée sur les étals des bouteilles
venus du monde entier
on a des produits de qui vient du pays
de l'est on assurerait un vin moldave
ont fait également des petits karam
devant blonde me sucrer que l'on peut
accompagner on apéritif je propose a
également invoqué qui vient d'ukraine
des bières que je fais importés
directement de la russie retrouvée pour
tous les goûts pour tous les types de
perth
cette diversité c'est le reflet du
parcours d'aram à 27 ans seulement il a
déjà travaillé dans plusieurs endroits
du globe
l'arménie dont il est originaire mais
aussi la russie un chemin qui a fait la
différence
le plus values les atouts c'est que je
connais beaucoup de produits qu'on
connaît pas en france les vins les vins
des pays de l'est
les digestifs etc j'ai pris le risque
d'un lancer de demont partons de rien et
puis j'ai eu beaucoup de soutien et
beaucoup d'encouragements
le meilleur soutien d'un ram c'est sa
femme clémentine
forte d'une expérience commerciale elle
assure l'accueil l'agencement de la
boutique et sa promotion sur les réseaux
sociaux
et il n'était pas trop de deux pour
partager les efforts qu implique
l'ouverture d'un commerce
[Musique]
au début quand on s'est installé en
travail 7 sur 7 sans aucun repos pendant
plusieurs mois et par la suite on a
commencé à fermer un jour par semaine il
fort d'avoir une seule journée de se
reposer parce que c'est presque pas
possible de ne pas avoir quinze jours de
congé avant que dans ce local beaucoup
de commerces ont fait faillite pour
durer et se faire connaître ils ont
choisi de diversifier leurs activités en
proposant des services annexes comme la
gestion de colis disons que le plombier
rendre à mourir en classe a avec
d'autres un peu et puis il faut beaucoup
de choses des banquets des super
des clients nombreux investir la
boutique en quête de conseils la
spécialité d'aram diplômés en oenologie
incollable sur ces produits est apte à
faire face aux salves de questions on
m'a parlé d'un japonais alors les jambes
alors qu'est-ce qu'ils ont des
particuliers alors le japonais oui
en 2007 il était meilleur au monde après
je peux vous conseiller un combiné il
est à 25 euros
aram a le sourire il fait le métier dont
il rêvait et pense maintenant à son
prochain objectif celui d'ouvrir un bar
à vin pour prolonger ces instants avec
ses clients